tout ça vraiment lamentable si vous
permettez de propos un peu grossi ce
vraiment d'un politique de merde c'est
la politique
françois deseille sort de ses gonds
l'adjoint au maire en charge du projet
de la cité internationale de la
gastronomie s'en prend directement à
emmanuel bichot en cause l'un des
recours déposés par l'élu d'opposition
un coup de sang un peu théâtral mais
qu'on se rassure un moins de deux ans
des élections municipales
il n'y a là aucune arrière pensée
politique ce rapport ce n'est pas un
acte politique l'acte politique c'est
pas nous qui le joue
moi j'en ai assez de voir de prendre en
otage ce projet moi j'ai pas que ça à
faire j'ai une profession à côté j'adore
ce projet font que ça avance c'est pas
dans dix ans on va pas faire une hymne
au bis ou des gens bloquent et puis
finalement ça va se faire non moi ce que
j'ai envie que cette cité elles sortent
un peu importe quelle sorte en 2020
avant les élections après les élections
on s'en fiche c'est un projet qui va
booster dijon sur le site de l'ancien
hôpital les travaux de terrassement ont
bel et bien commencé mais l'amérique est
inquiète
le recours déposé par emmanuel bichot
rendrait les investisseurs frileux
l'élu d'opposition estime lui que
l'équipe municipale a mal ficelé son
projet est plutôt que de chercher à
pointer du doigt tel ou tel que personne
je pense qu'elle ferait mieux de
s'interroger sur en réalité les
difficultés intrinsèques du projet
n'importe quel investisseur sérieux si
vous voulez indépendamment notre recours
bien si vous voulez va quand même se
demander si le montage juridique et
sérieux entrepreneurs artisans locaux
mais aussi commerçants à dijon ils sont
pourtant nombreux attendent cette cité
de la gastronomie
tous espèrent bénéficier de sa
fréquentation c'est un point
d'attraction
on va dire de challans venant de
l'extérieur qui peuvent venir un petit
peu compensé justement le manque de
fréquentation du centre ville par un peu
les dijonnais puis les gens de la
première couronne
donc c'est un flux qui va se jouer là
bas et qui va venir jusqu'à nous ici en
centre ville
difficile aujourd'hui de dire si le
projet a du plomb dans l aile l'examen
du recours d'emmanuel bichot pourrait
lever quelques doutes mais pour l'heure
aucune audience déprogrammé au tribunal
administratif de lyon
[Musique]